bonjour karine huet merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur rt france
après l'odéon au moins trois autres
théâtres sont occupés depuis hier jusqu
où le mouvement peut-il s'étendre ces
prochains jours
bonjour à tout le monde déjà il va
s'étendre
il peut s'étendre beaucoup plus loin
parce que vous parlez 3 je crois que ces
quatre yahia l'opéra graslin à nantes
qui est occupé depuis dix ans plus c'est
encore c'est encore petit ce qui est je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
prépare et que une ouverture des salles
en général et une occupation nous ont
fait un appel à occuper pour nous aider
pour soutenir des revendications ici
toute la france dans la sphère on a fait
un communiqué là-dessus si on veut
obtenir des shows si on veut être écouté
par les gens qui peuvent décider
il va falloir durcir encore là les
actions et qu'on entend cette
mobilisation nationale qui est national
on l'a compris de toute façon puisque le
4 mars
il n'y avait pas que paris en
manifestation il y avait 25 30 ou 35
autres villes qui manifestaient ce
jour-là déjà votre protestation dure
depuis maintenant une semaine
comment est ce qu'elle est accueilli par
les parisiens autour du théâtre de
l'odéon qui passe aux alentours
est ce que vous sentez un engouement
populaire autour de votre cause
mais écoutez oui nous va pas fin prêt je
vous parle de l'intérieur depuis sept
jours de ce que je peux voir devant les
grilles quand je descends bas parce que
voilà et de ce que je peux voir de la
terrasse quand je suis tout en haut on
nous amène des gâteaux des gens nous ont
fait des choix la crème qu'on a trouvé
dans une boîte où nous on ne demande pas
si on a besoin de choses et on a en a
blow n'a beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
gens qui passent qui viennent voyez
avant les agoras les musiciens qui
viennent jouer les fonds phare qui avec
la la il ya une fanfare qui est resté
qui vient de finir la vie qu'à jouer
quand même un bon moment après après
l'agora donc on ressent beaucoup de
soutien et même tard le soir on a encore
les gens qui passent des fois qu'ils
viennent discuter on discute de temps en
temps avec les sdf de ce qu'ont fait nos
tours de garde
voilà on leur donne un peu on partage ce
qu'on est avec eux quand ils passent ccd
moment de ville que je n'aurais jamais
imaginé vivre que de faire des gardes
entre 3 4 heures du matin louis
decarnelle dans le daeu vous dites que
des personnes passent à vous voir il ya
une personne
personne connue qui est passé vous voir
samedi dernier c'est la ministre de la
culture roselyne bachelot qu'est ce que
vous retenez de son passage et qu'est ce
que vous lui demandez écouter ce qu'on
retient de son passage c'est qu'elle
n'avait aucune annonce qu'elle est juste
passé nous voir je ne sais pas bien
pourquoi faire en fait parce que voir ce
qu'on lui demande elle sait c'est en lui
demandant on sait déjà que chez les
artistes et les techniciens
le 31 ne suffira pas nous avons aucune
visibilité devons nous pour savoir ce
qui va se passer au niveau du travail
on sait que cet été ça peut reprendre un
peu au niveau du style festival mais
c'est quand même des formules réduite
d'ondés programmation réduite
il ya donne deux spectacles qui ne
s'adapte pas à la jauge à 6
les journées les musiciens vont chez
nous par exemple qui font de la danse
qui font du spectacle debout ils vont
être sans travail encore son compte et
tout le secteur occasionnels et et puis
la jauge de 5000 personnes à 6,1 pour
pour les festivaliers des festivals
comme le hellfest notamment qui qui se
plaint de cela vous avez parlé également
de la date du 31 août c'est la fin des
aides pour les intermittents vous vous
appelez à ce que cette aide sur
prolongée jusqu'à quand jusqu'où
à la fin de l'année la fin d'année 2022
du coup ne peux pas donner de date parce
que on pourrait le lean date si on
savait quand le compte que quand la
relance va repartir quand on pourra
retravailler pour l'instant aujourd'hui
on n'a aucune idée de la date
d'ouverture des salles les festivals
vont fonctionner d'une manière
restreinte comme je vous dis est-ce
qu'en septembre ça va repartir
comment on ne sait pas il va falloir
qu'on se donne une date par rapport à
une décision qui sera prise et voilà oui
c'est sans doute une commission
sanitaire qui peut décider ça ou insérés
ps avec tout le monde l'a pour l'instant
je lui dis des choses des idées comme ça
parce que c'est pas décidé
en tout cas nous on a pas données datent
donc on n'a pas de précision sur
l'avenue dans tous les cas à tel aviv
il ya une date c'était ce week end il ya
eu un concert qui a eu lieu dans un
stade
et hier aux pays bas mille trois cents
personnes ont participé à un compte
certes est les festivaliers divisé en
six bus l'un avec des consignes
sanitaires à respecter une opération de
la sorte
est ce qu'elle peut être envisagée à
court terme en france c'est sans doute
financièrement assez important cesser si
c'est dur très court terme
est ce que est ce que s'il va avoir une
rentabilité importante pour le faire
c'est sans doute là le nombre de temps
on va rester sans travail et qui peut
dire ça aujourd'hui comment la part il
ya déconcertait ce qu'ils sont franches
on est quand même très très en retard là
dessus après aujourd'hui on a quand même
un protocole sanitaire qui a été discuté
qui a été hacké lâche si on veut les
lieux avec le protocole sanitaire
existants je pense que c'est possible
quand on voit la pression hospitalière
4000 personnes en réanimation cas qu'une
passion du coc vide dont 1000 à paris
avec des évacuations à venir selon les
mots aujourd'hui tu porte parole du
gouvernement
vous comprenez la prudence de l'exécutif
vis à vis de cette situation sanitaire
précaire
aminu comprend ou comprend sept noms
démis en veux absolument pas que
que le virgule virus here que le plus on
veut on veut que les gens qui qui n'ont
plus qui ont baissé de revenus des fois
divisé par deux pour ceux qui sont
indemnisés pour ceux qui sont pas
indemnisés mais pas du tout faisons rien
il joue arrière et ça et pour les pour
des femmes enceintes qui ont perdu tous
leurs droits sociaux pour des gens qui
ont un cancer en ce moment qui le
trouvent ils n'ont plus de darel ou
maladie de manière normale comme avant
ça ça doit être établi si vous voulez au
concours nous empêche de travailler
parce que voilà
mais après c'est un choix les centres
commerciaux et de fermer les salles
aussi un choix politique donc
donc voilà en tout cas notre
revendication avait quand même beaucoup
plus basé sur le fait que les gens
soient au dessus du minimum de pauvreté
aujourd'hui en france tous et que l'on
maintient les droits sociaux pour
toulouse merci terrain nu est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général adjoint du
snam cgt l'union nationale des syndicats
d'artistes musiciens de france